so this could be a new thing that they
do is they're all into like getting
kicked as many times in the nuts as
possible and then all the optimal human
podcasts get on and they go you know
it's funny uh
dominatrix isn't a thing you know people
like to present it as this sort of genre
of pornography or sex but it's just a
weak mind
for example I train my body for a good
three months and I performed a study a
case study on my own I met up with over
a hundred dominatrix in a parking lot
and I stood there in a small speed up
to see if they could humiliate me I let
each of them kick me in the balls 30
times you know what I found out
getting kicked in the nuts is healthy
another fun side effect my [__] and
balls are unrecognizable
fully just mutilated
it's a swollen mess down there
I can't pee anymore can't pee I can't
come
but you don't you don't need those
things